bonjour monsieur
alors qu'est ce qui vous arrive de tordu
la cheville ce matin pas de fracture
heureusement pour ce patient admis aux
urgences de l'hôpital privé de trappes
il devra néanmoins immobilisé sa
cheville pendant près d'un mois les
intentions à ses fréquentes traumatisme
de sport traumatisme par lissade
actuellement le que les intempéries avec
plus de cinquante mille passages par an
le service des urgences a été rénové en
juin dernier
la capacité d'accueil a été augmentée
l'accueil des patients a été repensé
afin de réduire le temps d'attentes
nous agissons sur toutes les étapes de
la prise en charge à savoir de l'accueil
administratif jusqu'à la sortie du
patient entre ensemble par l'infirmier
d'accueil et d'orientation et la mise en
place chez nous depuis l'année dernière
d'un médecin d'accueil et d'orientation
des écrans permettent d'en savoir plus
sur les délais d'attentes en
traumatologie en médecine une salle de
radiologie est au coeur du service des
urgences ce qui permet aux médecins de
rendre leur diagnostic plus rapidement
exemple avec cette patiente qui a glissé
sur une plaque de verglas en se rendant
à son travail
donc là ce qui se passe c'est que vous
avez un traumatisé du poignet avec une
fracture qui est un petit peu déplacé
donc ce qu'on va faire c'est que j'ai
demandé un avis à l'orthopédie ce sos
mains ça peut nécessiter une petite
révolution blocs opératoires des
urgences rénové qui permettent donc une
meilleure prise en charge des patients
plus nombreux en cette période hivernale